the henderson-hasselbalch equation is an
equation that's often used to calculate
the ph of buffer solutions
buffers consists of a weak acid and its
conjugate base so for a generic weak
acid we could call that h a
and therefore its conjugate base would
be a minus
to calculate the ph of the buffer
solution we would find the pka of the
weak acid and to that we would add the
log of the concentration of the
conjugate base divided by the
concentration of the weak acid
let's use the henderson-hasselbalch
equation to calculate the ph of an
aqueous buffer solution that consists of
acetic acid and its conjugate base the
acetate anion and let's use this
particulate diagram to help us calculate
the ph of the buffer solution remember
that the goal of a particulate diagram
is not to represent every particle in
the solution but to give us an idea
about what's going on in the entire
solution and also when looking at the
particulate diagrams of buffer solutions
water molecules and cations are often
left out for clarity
let's count the number of particles of
acetic acid in our particulate diagram
so in our diagram there are five
particles of acetic acid and for the
acetate anion there are also five
because there are five particles of both
acetic acid and the acetate anion the
concentration of acetic acid
is equal to the concentration of the
acetate anion
next let's think about the
henderson-hasselbalch equation our goal
is to calculate the ph of this buffer
solution represented in the particular
diagram and so first we need to know the
pka of the weak acid which is acetic
acid
at 25 degrees celsius the ka value for
acetic acid is equal to 1.8 times 10 to
the negative fifth the ka value is less
than one because acetic acid is a weak
acid to find the pka of acetic acid we
take the negative log of the ka value so
the negative log of 1.8 times 10 to the
negative fifth is equal to 4.74
so we can go back to the
henderson-hasselblack equation and write
that the ph is equal to the pka which we
just calculated to be
4.74
plus
the log of the concentration of the
conjugate base and the conjugate base is
the acetate anions let's write that in
here ch3
cool minus
and that's divided by the concentration
of the weak acid which is acetic acid
ch3cooh
we've already figured out that the
concentration of acetic acid is equal to
the concentration of the acetate anion
therefore the concentration of the
acetate anion divided by the
concentration of acetic acid is just
equal to one
and the log of one is equal to
zero so let's go ahead and write that in
here the log of one is equal to zero
therefore the ph of the buffer solution
is equal to 4.74
plus zero or just 4.74
so whenever the concentration of the
weak acid is equal to the concentration
of the conjugate base the ph of the
buffer solution is equal to the pka of
the weak acid
let's look at another particulate
diagram we still have an acetic acid
acetate buffer solution
however this is a different buffer
solution than the previous problem
so let's count our particles for acetic
acid there are six particles
and for the acetate anion there are only
four
since we have more acetic acid particles
than acetate particles the concentration
of acetic acid is greater than the
concentration of the acetate anion
we can use the henderson-hasselbach
equation to think about the ph of this
buffer solution so the ph is equal to
the pka which we calculated in the
previous problem for acetic acid it's
4.74 at 25 degrees celsius plus the log
of the concentration of the acetate
anion divided by the concentration of
acetic acid
in this case the concentration of acetic
acid is greater than the concentration
of the acetate anion therefore
we have a smaller concentration divided
by a larger concentration so we have a
number less than one
and the log of a number less than one is
negative therefore all of this would be
negative or less than zero
so we would be subtracting a number from
4.74
therefore we can say the ph of the
solution
would be less than 4.74
let's do one more particulate diagram of
an acetic acid acetate buffer solution
once again we count our particles so for
acetic acid this time there are four
particles and for the acetate and ion
this time there are six particles
since we have
only four particles of acetic acid and
six particles of the acetate anion the
concentration of acetic acid is less
than the concentration of the acetate
anion or we could say the concentration
of the acetate anion is greater than the
concentration of acetic acid
thinking about the henderson hasselbach
equation once again the pka is equal to
4.74
and we need to think about the ratio of
the concentration of the acetate anion
to the concentration of acetic acid for
this example the concentration of the
acetate anion is greater than the
concentration of acetic acid
therefore the ratio would be greater
than one
and the log of a number greater than one
is positive or greater than zero
therefore we would be adding a number to
4.74
so for this buffer solution the ph would
be greater than 4.74
finally let's summarize what we've
learned from our three different
particulate diagrams
in the first example the concentration
of the weak acid was equal to the
concentration of the conjugate base and
therefore the ph of the buffer solution
was equal to the pka of the weak acid
in the second example the concentration
of the weak acid was greater than the
concentration of the conjugate base and
therefore the ph of the buffer solution
is less than the pka of the weak acid
and in the third example the
concentration of the weak acid was less
than the concentration of the conjugate
base therefore the ph of the buffer
solution was greater than the pka of the
weak acid
so if we know the ph of a buffer
solution we can think about the
henderson-hasselbalch equation to think
about the relative concentrations of the
weak acid and the conjugate base
for example if we have a particular
buffer solution and we know the ph of
the buffer solution is less than the pka
of the weak acid we know that in that
buffer at that moment in time the
concentration of the weak acid is
greater than the concentration of the
conjugate base